okay so don't freak out but i did spend
a lot of time
doing this we're probably gonna have to
chat soon
whoa boys because of legal reasons
all i'm allowed to say right now is this
do not believe
what you're hearing online a frasier k
reportedly found a seasoned assist
against coffeezilla which is why i'm
making this video to inform the boys
frazier's law firm that unfortunately
i'm gonna miss the deadline boys now
where it gets
very very interesting is also the
accusation surfacing around what seems
to be a
former faze clan manager known as jordan
galen
there's even more to this okay because
sam pepper before any of this happened
was involved in his own pump and dump
scandal
and i say somebody investigate sam
pepper on last week's mom's basement you
know what that kid did sam pepper
he privated his twitter guys this has
gone so beyond
social media drama at this point like
there's legal implications for these
guys i'm sure
all of these people making videos think
that they know the truth and that they
know who's responsible
when they just don't
all right guys welcome to the final part
of our story on save the kids taking a
while
we got here save the kids was a crypto
charity coin as many of you know that
turned out to be a scam
it was promoted by some of the biggest
influencers in the world and for the
past few weeks barely sociable mudahar
and myself have been working to uncover
the truth of what happened this will be
my final contribution to the story so
far we've given everyone a lot in terms
of evidence but i think it's time to
zoom out a bit and so in this finale i'm
going to try to make it so that
everyone can understand it and see this
whole thing for what it was
and i'm going to be trying to create
using the best available information
a narrative on what exactly happened who
changed the anti-whale code
who started the coin who's been writing
these deals i'll do my best to answer
all of those questions but bear in mind
you have to understand that many of
these people with key
information aren't talking they're
scared of law enforcement some of them
might even be on the run and others are
just simply lying to me
but i'm not just here to talk about
who's guilty i also want to clear up
anyone who got caught up in this but
anyways
without further ado let's get to the
bottom of what is
in my opinion the most complicated
crypto scam of this year
ladies and gentlemen welcome to the 10
million dollar studio i'm your host
coffeezilla the internet detective and
where we
last left things we didn't know who the
mastermind was we had key players we
also had some people who sold some save
the kids token but didn't have a pattern
of malicious selling and we also had a
bunch of question marks unknown wallets
and people who
we really didn't know their level of
involvement with this whole thing
and some people we didn't know if they
were relevant or not remember
this guy named manny seemed to be
involved but we didn't know who that was
and a lot has happened since that first
video went
live the first thing was that nearly
right after i put it up
i get hit up by none other than manny
and he said
his whole role in this thing has been
misunderstood he wasn't some big
mastermind he was just a connection guy
yeah so
me and fraser were in this one group
chat and uh it's a paid to they get to
pay to get in or you have to have
one million dollars in crypto and
through here he asked yo i need a dev
and i'm like i have a dev uh and that
brings me to lucas
that was my role i was hands off from
there pretty much
all right so we can kind of cross his
name off
it isn't a lot but it's a start there
are a lot more names we have to check
into
so the next thing we did was hunt for
more wallets of people who were involved
and that's when we got pinged by one of
the founders of moon portal
remember this was one of the scams that
was promoted by a lot of these
so-called influencers and this developer
told us that influencers ruined his
project and because of that he decided
to give us
the wallets of several famous
influencers
who were involved in his pre-sale among
them
rice gum so this is it the alleged
wallet it looks like on
june 6th he got some money from the
pre-sell
and uh 30 minutes later he starts
selling it off
then he waits a couple hours and sells
off the rest
so after a few hours ricegum has seven
kids to his name
which based on the fact this guy's an
ambassador of the project is a pretty
scumbag thing to do
however looking through his other token
history this guy
isn't a crypto mastermind if i can be
honest ricegum
is from what i can see not smart
even though he abandoned save the kids
seemingly at his earliest convenience
i'd put him more in a similar category
as jarvis
or nikan who we talked about last time
as selling off some of their save the
kids token but
not having a pattern of malicious
selling
i think that's really important as we go
through this and pretty soon
after we got this lucky break finding
rice gum we got another lead when we
heard that
one of the influencers involved tico
wanted to volunteer his wallet saying
he had nothing to hide we of course took
him up on that
and here it is tico's wallet now let me
tell you up front
tico is probably the only person in this
whole story i feel bad for
because we have him on blockchain record
putting in
roughly 40 000 worth of crypto into save
the kids token
and then just not selling at all as you
can see he bought some here
uh he even bought more from pancake swap
and just held on to it
as it tanked to basically zero which
means that in
all of this tico seems to be the only
one who
actually wanted to help save any kids
now
as we were hunting for these other
wallets we found
something that we didn't expect see our
plan was to trace back the scams as we
had in the past
and talk to some of the developers and
among them we kept hearing
a name pop up jordan galen and i want to
say
i didn't mention him in the first video
because i had never heard of him
before i didn't even know he was
involved in save the kids but the more
we explored projects beyond just save
the kids his name
kept popping up as someone who is
organizing these deals
here for instance is a text from jordan
galen to the moon portal team
hey hazim i was telling gabe that
officially confirmed
is fraser jarvis rice gum me
waiting on official confirmation from
aidan banks and will circle back shortly
now this hazim he addresses i actually
spoke to
he filled me in on how all this worked
apparently jordan was the go-to guy
on these guys behalf now to be clear you
guys got a lot of these
influencers by talking through jordan
right
uh everyone or most of them other than
pomp and rage
hmm seems like a lot of influence who is
this jordan guy
well according to his linkedin he is the
senior talent manager
at faze clan and he admits he was
brokering crypto deals for talent such
as
kay jarvis and the rest when i asked him
about it he said quote
this began with me answering emails that
were sent into fraser's inbox
after a few of the deals i got in
contact with a party who then brought in
a bulk of the deals to me and that's it
and you might be asking what did jordan
get out of all this
well commission according to him and we
were talking about frazier's deals
specifically here
quote after fraser was sent the money he
sent
me between 10 to 20 percent of what he
got there was never formal conversations
about commission since fraser just
always took care of me
on every deal we did so it seems like
jordan galen's the guy going out there
getting the deals negotiating the terms
and this is later sort of confirmed when
we found such a deal
in negotiation it actually fell through
so it never happened but
it gives you an idea of the numbers we
could be talking about here
k was supposed to promote something
called ape haven token
and at the time they were negotiating to
be paid over
half a million dollars of which 150
000 would have been part of a giveaway
to promote the coin which would have put
jordan's commission at around 40 to 80
000 with k's cut being 350 000
which isn't bad for a few tweets and a
little promotion
and we actually obtained footage of this
negotiation taking place
we're super excited to get started um
frasier's ready to kind of start
formulating drafting his tweets for
tonight now this negotiation goes on for
a while of when these tweets
are going out but i noticed that jordan
galen was doing most of the talking
and later the call is wrapped up rather
strangely
we're down we're down to go now man we
go to the moon tonight
and then we start going over to mars and
we get all the way to pluto let's do it
i'll see you there now unfortunately
since this deal did not work out
we don't know if they made it to pluto
or not but we know how these deals were
getting to k
and others jordan was hunting them down
but not just
for faze members for others like ricegum
as well
this brings up kind of an important
question if a talent manager
for faze clan was involved did faze
as an organization know about this i've
spoken extensively to everyone i could
about this
starting with faye's banks he
immediately denied any knowledge and
after hearing what jordan galen had done
faze clan promptly fired him i asked
jordan galen if any of these deals had
crossed faze clan's desks and he
responded
quote no i didn't bring in the deals
through the paths i usually did
and was working with talent directly
there were no agreements so there was
nothing ever to sin
phase legal to review nor did fayes get
any financial cut on these deals
this corroborates what he'd tell me
later jordan told me quote
there were no contracts either now given
all of this
i'm comfortable saying phase as an
organization
didn't know what was going on with these
crypto deals because
it just kind of doesn't make sense if
phase knew they'd want a piece of the
pie
and the other part of this is that if
they knew they probably would have
vetoed it because
why risk in a hundred million dollar
plus brand
for a 40 grand payout over here or there
you know it just
it doesn't make sense but if you're a
talent manager who's looking to get paid
a little bit
on the side i don't know i think that
just makes a little bit more sense that
way
and this doesn't mean that i'm i endorse
phase or i'm
phasing up or whatever i've just i've
seen so much flack online that this
whole thing is a phase conspiracy
and how phase new and all this kind of
stuff and from what i've seen
that simply isn't true but okay if faze
the
organization didn't know who did know
somebody had to put this thing together
who is left after we check off
box after box well three people
seemed to me to be at the heart of this
fraser k
who sent me a cease and desist letter
shortly after my second video
you have sam pepper who lived with kay
and has been known in the crypto
industry for a while now
as someone who constantly shills
worthless coins and of course
jordan galen a rogue manager running
crypto deals and here's what i wanted to
know
okay they're running this crypto game
for a while where they post about a coin
get a bunch of money immediately sell it
delete the posts
but how long was this pump and dump type
scheme
happening how far did it really go for
this i had to go
deep on the blockchain so i spent
several late nights tracking down
every transaction i could and trying to
get to the bottom of this thing
and what i found out was that this thing
went deeper
than i ever could have imagined okay so
don't
freak out but i did spend a lot of time
doing this
i know how insane it looks it looks like
i'm about to bring up carol from hr
okay but i'm not this is genuinely the
best way
to visualize what we've found here we
mapped out the blockchain crypto
transactions between
three people we know about k we have
jordan galen
and we have sam pepper and we map these
out in order to find out
where their connections are so let me
tell you how this works
in pink are the altcoins and purple
are the main wallets so here we have
fraser's main wallet
right here we have jordan galen's main
wallet and up here
sam pepper's main wallet and i also
threw in
jarvis over here in order to show you
guys the difference between a normal
wallet
and the rest of these guys so over here
it's just one wallet
and it's connected to three things save
the kids doge elon
and jordan galen comparatively look at
someone like kay he's tied
to nearly everything different wallets
different crypto coins
he's moving money between different
accounts like for instance
this whale wallet for k and what we've
done
is color coded each wallet we believe
these guys control
k for instance we colored in light brown
the wallets we believe jordan controls
in light blue
and the wallets that sam pepper controls
in green
all in order to give you a better
understanding of their operations
and the reason we went through all this
trouble is because if i sat here and
walked you through
each and every transaction you'd get
lost
because it wasn't always their main
wallets doing the sketchy business
here's a small example see ox e40 here
frazier funded it on may 7th by sending
5.1 bmb from his main wallet
that wallet then bought pluto which
frazier
promoted and then this wallet sent that
pluto back to two
different wallets one of them is
fraser's main wallet
and another one is a wallet he's linked
to ox-881
both of these wallets then immediately
dumped that pluto
but if i explain that to you with just
wallet numbers and just in transactions
it's easy to get confused but with this
map we can see how they're linked and
ultimately
it isn't about one transaction or
another that's not the point
the point is that these people aren't
amateurs
so if they try to come out and tell you
that they thought this was just like any
other brand deal
or they didn't know what they were doing
or they're new to crypto it's just not
true
this scheme is incredibly complicated
k and sam pepper both have wallets
the way a janitor has keys and i believe
they use them to hide the full scope of
what they were doing and the question is
of course why if you're not trying to
cover something
up why have five 10 20 wallets why
shuffle
your money around like you're playing a
game of three card monty
i think the answer is obvious and what's
also clear
is that k and sam pepper they worked
closely together because
with things like moon pub we've
previously discussed how k
made roughly a hundred thousand dollars
from it but
pepper was also involved over here
and the other thing we learned is that
jordan galen over here
he seems to be instrumental in finding
these deals
4k he has less wallets than either one
of these guys but
he was key to getting these deals done
for example
hazim the moon portal developer we've
heard from earlier
told me that when he reached out to kay
kay insisted
on having jordan involved he was
actually the first one i reached out to
and he said that we had to have a
conversation with the jordan president
so we hopped on a group call
together okay so we know jordan is tied
up
with k and sam pepper and k
are working closely together and
basically they would run these crypto
deals
sometimes in their main wallets
sometimes not they promote these coins
dump these coins and then
delete the posts but now that the stage
is set now that we've
found out how this all worked we're
almost ready to save the kids but first
i want to clear up something
from the last video in mudahar's last
video we had highlighted some of the
problems
with these token giveaways where some of
the giveaways
seem to go to wallet's link to k for
example
this wallet which won three of fraser
k's
giveaways in a row in the exact giveaway
amounts we also highlighted when fraser
announced a giveaway
for the token milf quote i'll give 500
to a random person in 24 hours who likes
this tweet
good luck and not financial advice now
who was the one person who got paid in
milf token
in that 24 hour period it was jordan
galen
and we said at the time this looks like
giveaway fraud
but jordan was adamant that no such
giveaway fraud had happened
that this was his commission fee he told
us not giveaway winnings
which fair enough call it commission
call it
whatever you want the fact is jordan
immediately
sold that milf token right after as kay
was tweeting
and hyping up these tokens now with that
short correction out of the way and now
that you
understand the key players and their
history with crypto
let's talk about save the kids all three
of these guys
kay galen and sam pepper bought into the
pre-sale but
were they all equally responsible who's
in charge
well as i was trying to figure it out
someone who i wasn't expecting
suddenly reached out we're probably
gonna have to chat
soon whoa boys okay
sorry i had to move we had to go back in
front of the screen for this
um obviously when i saw this my mind was
blown we've been trying to get a hold of
this guy
like forever he's one of the key players
here
so immediately i respond hey got time
now and then i gave him some contact
information
and then for probably i don't know five
minutes
i just see these three bubbles that are
killing me and my heart is just like
pounding
because this guy could be the key to
this whole thing this whole save the
kids thing he's
maybe the missing link but then he
replies
sorry mate moving all this means
the house closed down and everything
will most likely be next week keep this
between us until then
i don't want to create any unnecessary
drama till we fully get to talk start to
finish
of what happened i got to tell you guys
being this
close to it this deep in the
investigation and almost getting this
guy to talk only to be pushed off
was just killing me and because at this
point we have to play
a waiting game right but we did learn
something it seems like whatever
friendship him and kay had seems to have
disintegrated
because moving out of k's house where
they lived
meant they wouldn't be working together
anymore but while i waited for a
response for him to get back with me
i got sent an anonymous email that
caught me off guard
in it was a recorded call with lucas the
developer
you guys should remember him from the
last episode he designed
the save the kids project code he also
changed
the whale code but said he was just
doing that because he was told to
coffee this is what i was told to do i'm
contracted i don't know what to tell you
and in this new recording he finally
points the finger at who told him
to change that whale code this is a big
argument between the devs to uh change
the code and the dev's trend to
not want to choose the code always
explaining why this 24 hours was
necessary
um but there is a behind the scenes
manager who
mainly pushed this this was sam's
pushing trying to argue the devs that
the uh the code should have been changed
so it was a lot less limiting
whoa so sam pepper
was the one behind the whale code change
i asked lucas myself
and he confirmed it now full disclosure
i think the email
containing that video about pepper
is from kay just anonymously now i have
no hard proof of that but the tone of
the email sounded like it was from kay
or his team and it's worth knowing that
as we move forward because later
it emailed me a bunch of really personal
information about pepper like
literally a photo of sam pepper seeming
like he was just going out to his car or
something
like he was being watched without his
knowledge by some kind of a private
investigator
but regardless whoever was sending me
this information was pretty obvious that
i wasn't the only one investigating sam
other people
wanted to know what he was up to as well
and then i got another email
i know lots of emails here this time
from an ex-sam pepper fan who invested
in the coin
himself through sam pepper he showed me
that sam was actually part of the
promotion of this coin
because he ran his own version of the
pre-sale list
this is a list of people sam pepper got
to put in money
and got them save the kids before the
public could ever get involved
now i analyzed what these people did
with their coins and it turns out
a huge proportion of these guys dumped
their coins
three to four hours after launch which
may have been part of the cause
for why the coin got rocked but at this
point i'm thinking
sam clearly played a hand in the rug
pull
in this whole thing turning out to be a
scam but right as i was thinking that he
was responsible for everything
suddenly we get a response from sam
pepper
it's long and full of pr so let me give
you
the important part i've been a paid
consultant to k
for two years i took orders from him and
had no authority independent of him
everyone knows that kay does what he
wants and doesn't do anything he doesn't
want to do
even if others want him to do it
everyone knows that too
the name concept and aspects of save the
kids coin
were kaye's idea and he chose and
assembled team members
he controls that's what kate does
okay obviously we have to take this with
a huge grain of salt
coming from pepper because everyone's
playing this like pr game at this point
but
what if there is some truth to this was
kay behind
save the kids token launch i mean he
made himself seem like another
ambassador
but what if he's the one who launched it
then i get sent this picture
from sam pepper to confirm what he's
saying it's a message from
k on may 21 founder of coinmarketcap
heard i'm starting this and reached out
to call me later
wow now pay attention to these dates
here because this is important
this was allegedly sent on may 21st 2021
and presumably he's talking about
save the kids here because when you go
look up the domain
for save the kids guess when it was
created may 20th
a day before so a day after this
save the kids dot io website is created
right here
k is contacted by the founder of coin
market cap
now i reached out to kay to try to
confirm this screenshot's
existence because obviously i don't
trust sam pepper as far as i can throw
him but kay didn't respond
but even without all this right
everything does seem to point at
kay starting this coin we know that he's
the one who brought on
lucas the developer we know he used
manny's connections
we also know he brought on sam pepper to
mod this thing up
and you know what else this giant
pre-sale wallet that everyone's been
sending money to
this one right here it looks like k
might control that too
it was active after the pre-sale money
was sent
and even sent twenty thousand dollars to
an address
linked to kay all of this evidence
points to k
at least being the creator of this coin
but it doesn't take away from the fact
that it seems to be pepper who doomed
the coin by changing the whale code and
of course
where does uh our good buddy jordan
galen fit into all this
we know that he's been facilitating a
lot of these deals but
on save the kids his role does seem to
be a little bit more low-key
he seems less involved he initially
insisted
that he had nothing to do with the coin
quote i want to be abundantly clear
i had nothing to do with the development
organization of talent marketing or
anything to do with save the kids coin i
responded
why are you lying and then sent him a
screenshot showing
him trying to onboard a popular youtuber
on to save the kids this text is from
jordan himself
quote hey great to be connected one of
the talents i represent face k
is one of the lead ambassadors for a new
crypto token launch
save the kids we would love to get this
person involved
now i'm not showing their name because
they decline the deal and i don't
want to just drag them into drama for no
reason but the point is
he clearly was working on some of the
organization of talent now when i showed
him this
jordan backpedaled he said if i tried to
have anyone be part of the project
it would be because either sam or
frazier requested
i reached out to a talent to see if they
were interested but i am being very
genuine when i say to you that i did not
have
any involvement and i'm not lying to
your face
interesting jordan would later tell me
that this is
the only person that he approached with
this deal so make of that
what you will going back to the wallet
map
i think a picture is starting to emerge
here given
our available facts a story of what
happened
so here is in my opinion what happened
with save the kids token given all this
new evidence
i think all three of these guys were
doing this crypto thing for a while
where early dumps meant big profits
jordan
is uh the deal guy we've got sam pepper
and we've got frasier k being more of
the crypto people
and then one day along comes kay and he
decides
you know what i want to start my own
charity coin
so he gets a bunch of big influencer
friends on board using
him and his manager jordan galen's
connections
then at some point sam pepper is brought
in on the team
maybe to mod this thing up which seems
to have been
a critical mistake maybe kaye thought
that because
sam pepper and him live together his
friend would act different for his
project
and not rug the coin i don't know but
then sam pepper starts selling off a
bunch of save the kids token
to his own gang of people and he
receives in exchange
a small fee of one bnb from many of
these wallets which he immediately then
sends
to his main wallet meanwhile k is
working on promotion and gets several
famous influencers
this of course hypes up all of their
fans who get their wallets ready for the
big day
but right before launch we have sam
pepper
who approaches lucas the developer with
the idea of changing
this whale code lucas says that he was
just following orders
and makes the change and all of this
dooms
save the kids token from the very start
then comes the day of launch this
project is supposed to be
unruggable but immediately the project
gets rugged as sellers take advantage of
sam pepper's
code change and then the price collapses
sam pepper's group seems to be one of
the first to fully jump ship
four hours in they were completely out
k isn't any better he started selling 40
minutes after launch
and continue selling until 24 hours
later he's out
too out of what looks like to be his
project that he started in the first
place jordan galen also abandoned the
project early he sold off
within about six hours kaye's influencer
friends who shot this embarrassing promo
well
they also sold some or all of their
tokens really quick
all except for tico of course who didn't
sell
any but with all of this cell pressure
the results
is obvious the project collapses all the
while the fans of these guys are
dumping money into a project that never
had a chance
except wait that isn't the full story
there's a bit more and i'm sorry
for adding this in it's 6 a.m on video
launch day and i'm still
getting new information on the fallout
of the story so i'm just gonna have to
shove this in somewhere
real quick because i've just found out
that sam pepper
fled to the u.s to go back to the uk
here's the evidence first i found a new
photo of sam pepper in the uk
you gotta appreciate the shirt he's
wearing that says paranoid nice
sam now of course you might say just
because he's in the uk
doesn't mean he's fleeing the country
could be coincidental travel and that's
true
but here's another piece of information
you should consider sam pepper had a
white tesla model 3
lease a fact that was told to me by the
person that i believe was working 4k
and was basically stalking sam pepper
remember they're the ones who emailed me
a really weird photo
of sam now they had told me that sam
sold his tesla
to a carmax location in escondido
california
right here now the problem is of course
i don't trust k
and they didn't give me much to go on
just a license plate number
which i confirmed was sam pepper's but
after days of searching i couldn't
confirm or find
at carmack not only that when i
approached pepper
he denied it i told him i'm hearing from
anonymous sources that you've sold
basically everything including your car
is that true he says what lol the
conspiracies are getting out of control
i said you didn't sell your tesla to
carmax
he responds i am completely lost to what
you're on about
but eventually the truth of course came
out i had an acquaintance in the car
industry call
these carmax locations and get
confirmation that sam pepper
did have a lease on that white tesla
model 3 and that he did sell it
because we found his car at the muriata
carmax location
which is a 33-mile drive north of where
we first heard he sold it
here's our call confirming that uh yes
sir and it's actually in morieta
california and here it is on their
website we found this with the stock
number we were given
it's the same vin as sam pepper's car
meaning he really did break his lease
about a year early
it's not yet available yet because of
how recently it was sold
so why sell your car why leave the
country
and why lie about it well obviously i
have my theories
but playing devil's advocate you might
say maybe this is just all coincidence
right
you know that sam happened to travel to
uk right after save the kids he was
deleting posts
right after save the kids and privateed
his twitter account right after save the
kids and ended his car lease
early right after save the kids and then
lied about that fact
maybe it's just all coincidence but in
my opinion
it looks like sam pepper is fleeing the
united states to escape legal
accountability
for what happened but i asked him about
this and he of course denies this
categorically
he said you're very dramatic i've been
waiting for kova to be in a place
where i can travel uk just released its
mass mandate and i haven't seen my
family in years several years
i private my twitter as i'm not tweeting
about crypto right now
and as there's clearly drama with
influencers talking about coins etc i
have hundreds of thousands of people who
can still see it
and if you're saying that i deleted
tweets then you can see that too not
much hiding or running going on there
i get that the storyline would further
your story and make more of an
interesting angle
but it factually isn't the truth now
worth noting he did not address
the lie about selling his tesla or the
fact he sold it at
all but i'm gonna just have to let you
guys decide
what the truth is did sam flee the uk or
was this all part of a
a regular trip to visit the family he
hasn't seen
in several years but anyway guys that's
the new evidence now back to a
more well-rested coffees of love all in
all that seems to be the story of
save the kids token i approached sam
pepper fraser k and jordan galen with my
account of the events
and where i could i've added in their
side of the story but besides that
i think something worth mentioning is
the only person who shared even the
slightest bit of regret so far
was jordan galen who responded to a
question of whether he felt remorse and
told me
absolutely at the time i was doing what
i felt would make frasier and the talent
happy
i didn't want to upset anyone by not
helping so i helped get on some calls
and negotiate deals and one thing led to
the next now
this obviously isn't the world's best
apology but
coming from the guy who probably had the
least to do with save the kids of these
three people
it's at least something you know k
meanwhile has dodged all responsibility
and tried to pin it on sam
sam in turn has tried to pin it all on k
saying he's the mastermind the reality
is
without the other one this would have
never happened without kay
creating and hyping up this worthless
coin this could have never happened and
without sam
changing the whale code last minute this
also could have never happened and the
irony to me is that before this falling
out these guys were clearly working
together in crypto
involved in the same coin so don't let
them fool you as they try to you know
point
point the finger at the other one
there's plenty of blame to go around
for both of them so there you go that's
the story
of save the kids oh and since i know
everyone's going to be asking me
about how much money everyone made let
me just get through this real quick
quick
i i just have no clue i thought i did
when i had just one wallet per person
but
now that there's like 20 wallets finding
an exact number unless you're like a
forensic accountant
is next to impossible given how
convoluted all these wallet transactions
can get
you guys saw the board but what i can
tell you is that
it wasn't a lot not on save the kids at
least pepper probably made the most
money since he sold the earliest but
the real money to me seems like it was
made earlier for these guys
back when k and pepper were on the same
team running these crypto deals
moon pug pluto eclipse tits coin safe
galaxy i think this is where these guys
made their real money
we know already that these deals could
easily net six figures for them so
they could be millionaires from this by
now and it's crazy to think that
if save the kids had never happened we
wouldn't know the extent of these other
stories
we wouldn't know how these influencers
have been taking advantage of their fans
and
obviously it goes beyond k and pepper
right
like just how many influencers have done
this deleted their tweets
and gotten away with it it's crazy to
think about but hopefully this series
has shown people that
hey we need regulation in crypto for
these promotions
and b once it's on the blockchain it's
forever so if you are an influencer who
thinks that you can delete some tweets
and never get caught you might be wrong
about that we will eventually find you
and we will expose you and hopefully
eventually
maybe the cops will pay attention to
what's going on here i don't know
like the fbi sec i do somebody else
needs to get involved in this besides me
i'm just gonna be straightforward with
you guys
because i'm about to go crazy watching
all this stuff uh
unfold so hopefully it's not just me
finding you and exposing you hopefully
it's those guys
because i'm kind of tired of looking at
the blockchain for now
anyways i think that's basically it for
me i'm gonna go
take a long nap probably drink a lot i'm
out of here
see ya i know what you need this ain't
what it seems
nothing but a trick trying to sell me on
a dream but that was where you lost me
wake up and smell the coffee